let's bring in Face the Nation moderator
Margaret Brennan Margaret good morning I
want to go back to the changes at the
White House here give us your sense
there's now a new National Security
Adviser that's going to be as Chip
mentioned a new Secretary of State how
how does this team get its act together
on the eve of these very important talks
with North Korea well defense secretary
Jim mattis has to be feeling very alone
right now he is one of the lone
moderates left at the table in that
National Security Council session and
that's saying a lot because you if you
remember it was maddest who was pushed
out of the Obama administration because
they thought he was too hardline on Iran
now he's the one cause pushing and
cautioning for restraint when it comes
to that nuclear deal and also he has
pushed back on this idea of a
pre-emptive rather than a preventative
war with North Korea so the president is
surrounding himself with Mike Pompeo
with John Bolton with a team that is
much more muscular in its approach to
foreign policy and much less embracing
of diplomacy as a way out remember it
was Rex Tillerson the Secretary of State
who was just pushed out who had been
pushing for talks now you have the
president saying he'll take those on
directly and it seems to be a very
different approach to finding a path
forward on that North Korea question and
the question of pre-emptive war were at
the 15th anniversary of the Iraq war
which President Trump said was one of
the biggest mistakes in American history
john bolton on the other hand supporter
of the iraq war and also has talked
about pre-emptive action in north korea
but what is the u.s. policy with respect
to regime change in North Korea and is
there any chance that would change John
you're asking for a doctrine that just
hasn't been articulated I mean when you
talk to diplomats they will tell you we
do not have a clear strategy articulated
for North Korea or Iran other than let's
try to avoid a war first with North
Korea with these foreign policy team
shakeups you also see this shake up in
terms of a plan of action and as you say
John Bolton has not only continued to
defend the Iraq war but if you look back
at what President Trump said on the
campaign trail he said that was a
catastrophic mistake he
firmly rejected this neoconservative
idea of being able to go in reshape a
country and change the trajectory of it
and yet that's what John Bolton has
continued to say he believes was the
right choice at the time so it's not
clear that you can draw out a trump
doctrine from some of these changes it
just seems the president is surrounding
himself with people who are hardline
people who can articulate their views
strongly on television like John Bolton
has and who seemed to be affirming what
he has campaigned on such as withdrawing
from the Iran nuclear deal all right
Margaret thanks lots lots to untangle
there on Sunday we'll be watching